nos piden simplificar la raíz cúbica de
8 a cuadrada ve a la quinta se cúbica la
manera más fácil de simplificar un
radical cúbico como estos tenemos que
extraer una raíz cúbica es factorizar la
expresión dentro del radical en términos
que son cubos perfectos y términos que
no lo son para los términos que son
cubos perfectos extraeremos su raíz
cúbica y la pondremos fuera el radical
mientras que los términos que no lo son
se quedarán dentro del radical
enfoquémonos en el 8 veamos si podemos
factorizar cubos perfectos o quizás es
un cubo perfecto en sí mismo
así es que 8 lo puedo escribir como 2
por 4 y 4 como 2 por 2 y aquí lo tenemos
2 al cubo es igual a 8 pongámoslo aquí 2
al cubo es igual a 8 y esto es
equivalente a decir que la raíz cúbica
de 8 es igual a 2
así es que 8 es un agradable cubo
perfecto enfoquémonos en estos otros
términos que tenemos aquí déjame
entonces reescribir el radical esto es
igual a la raíz cúbica
de 8 que ya sabemos que es una agradable
cubo perfecto luego tenemos a cuadrada a
cuadrada
no podemos factorizar lo más no puedo
factorizar un cubo perfecto bueno
podríamos hacer alguna manipulación pero
vamos a dejarlo por lo pronto como a
deja de ponerlo con otro color
vamos a dejarlo como a cuadrada ve a la
quinta ve a la quinta lo podemos
escribir como de kubica que multiplica a
be cuadrada de kubica que es un cubo
perfecto su raíz cúbica es b y esto
multiplicado por de cuadrada finalmente
se cúbica se kubica que también es un
cubo perfecto
la raíz cúbica de c kubica es c así es
que esto x se ubica ahora reescribamos
esta expresión ordenando los términos
tenemos raíz cúbica
de 8 es este término que tenemos aquí
que multiplica a raíz cúbica de kubica
que multiplica la raíz cúbica de b
kubica y que multiplica a la raíz cúbica
de ese cúbica la raíz cúbica de se
cúbica si es que ya tomamos en cuenta
este término este término y este otro
término y son los cubos perfectos los
pusimos al principio pero nos falta
considerar los que no son cubos
perfectos que os vamos a poner todos
bajo un gran radical es decir la raíz
cúbica de a cuadrada
la raíz cúbica de a cuadrada por b
cuadrada ahora la raíz cúbica de 8 es
igual a 2
la raíz cúbica de de kubica voy a
hacerlo con el mismo color
así nos apoyan los colores entender la
raíz cúbica debe cúbica es la raíz
cúbica de se cúbica s este término de
aquí raíz cúbica de a cuadrada de
cuadrada ya no podemos simplificar lo
más mejor podemos jugar un poco más con
él pero no vamos a dejar así este
radical cúbico o raíz cúbica depende de
cómo lo quieras llamar multiplicado
entonces por la raíz cúbica de a
cuadrada de cuadrada hemos concluido